it's great to be joined today by Tamela
summers who's a professor of philosophy
at the University of Houston also
co-hosts the podcast very bad Wizards
and his author of the new book why honor
matters honor is a super interesting
topic and I'm glad to have this
opportunity to talk to you about it you
know honor is in the political world
associated positively with elements of
society and also sometimes negatively
with such phenomena as for example honor
killings in some parts of the world and
I think in order to even start talking
about this Stambler it's a good idea to
first think about what we mean when we
say honor so so maybe that's a good
place to start when we talk about honor
in society what are we really talking
about
yeah I saw I was afraid you'd asked that
question because it's not an easy thing
to answer it's such a broad diffuse
concept it's a messy concept and it is
used in so many different ways it's I
think honestly the messiness of it the
complexity of it is one of the reasons
why philosophers have shied away from
studying it at all so that's my caveat
like the best I can do is give sort of a
brief impressionistic summary of what it
is at least that I am talking about in
the book yes so really briefly your
honor within an honor group or on our
community is your value or worth to the
group and this is both your perceived
worth so how the group perceives your
value but also your actual work your
there's an objective element to it as
well
so somebody in an honor culture who is
praised and honored and revered wants to
actually be worthy of that
of the merit that is attributed to them
so that's what honor is you know if
you're talking about how honored am i
that's I think what we mean by that
there's also I think some characteristic
features of Honor more honor oriented
communities in contrast to non honor
communities so communities where honor
is a more central value so for one thing
they tend to place a higher value on
virtues like courage hospitality loyalty
integrity and solidarity with the group
again this is on a spectrum but when you
talk about honor cultures these are the
kinds of values and traits that you find
are are advocated for there's also a
heightened concern or personal
reputation and also your group
reputation so how you are perceived
within the group is something that
matters to you if you're in an honor
culture a lot more than it would matter
to you if you're in a non honor culture
and then lastly along with that comes a
heightened sensitivity to insult or
slights or challenges to your reputation
or to your honor
so one way to move up in an honor
hierarchy within a group is to challenge
somebody above you to insult them and if
they don't respond if they don't stand
up for themselves then you can gain
honor at their expense
so honor communities embrace a strong
conviction that people should handle
their own business that they should
stand up for themselves when they're
challenged or insulted and they are
averse to turning to third parties to
resolve their own cotton
conflicts so this is why yeah I think
that that's a good there's I think a lot
there to sort of dig into so to pick
pick one of those things just because we
don't we don't have a completely
unlimited amount of time I'm interested
in some of the traits that you connected
honor to like for example to pick one
solidarity with a group or the group
when I was preparing for this interview
I found that the effect of honor within
a group or society is not necessarily
positive or negative unless you sort of
examine the particulars in terms of how
its applied sort of like religion right
you have a group that says well religion
is what gives purpose to life and
enables us to live morally and then you
have others who say actually no you
religion is completely unnecessary in
order to live a moral life and in
thinking about the solidarity with a
group that can be a good or a bad thing
right when one one obvious question
would be well with which group one could
have as a result of Honor more
solidarity towards their religious group
which might cause conflict within the
broader population as an example so is
there any way to start assessing in
terms of in an objective way the
positive and negative impacts of
differing degrees of Honor in a society
well I think a lot of that will depend
on the norms or the code of the
particular group in questions so one of
the things that is extremely flexible
across honor cultures of all sorts is
what are what are the behaviors that or
in character traits that will bring you
more honor and what are the character
traits or behaviors that will bring you
shame so they have these norms for
allocating honor within the group if
those norms are immoral norms you know
so something you mentioned honor
killings at if if the code within the
group is that a woman who is suspected
of having extramarital
Saxe the family will be shamed unless
they kill that woman you know that's a
terrible norm it's a morally atrocious
norm and so in that kind of community
the what honor causes people to do is
going to be something that we should
discourage I mean this is one of the
problems with honor is it doesn't really
place any limits inherently on what will
bring you honor and what will bring you
shame and so when those things are
things that are morally good then the
motivational power of Honor becomes a
huge advantage but when they're bad the
motivational power of Honor it becomes
something that we need to really worry
about so within the United States what
would be the sort of primary subcultures
or enclaves of society that are more
honor based so the military definitely
for one sometimes often explicitly the
Navy SEALs have a honor code that's
spelled out I think sports teams and
especially hockey teams and baseball
teams operate according to and on a
strong honor code often unwritten
written rules about respect and there's
a lot of collective punishment and
collective responsibility and that
feeling of loyalty and solidarity I
think you find in inner city or urban
neighborhoods you find a lot of honor
communities honor cultures now sometimes
these things emerge by necessity because
when you can't depend on law enforcement
to to keep you safe people often turn to
an honor
culture or an honor group as both a form
of community a form of being a part of
something being a being a identify being
able to identify with something but also
as a form of protection I'm curious
about the sports examples you gave I I
mean I follow all of the major sports to
some degree but I'm not I'm curious
about the ways in which baseball and
hockey function more with elements of
sort of an honor code than for example
like basketball and football well the
the the sort of prime examples in hockey
are the way that the fights operate so
there are people with very distinct
there are teammates with very distinct
roles there is the scorer and the score
is supposed to score and there is the
agitator the agitator is is supposed to
get under the opponent's skin and then
there are the enforcers who are supposed
to protect the team stand up for the
team and if somebody takes a cheap shot
at their skilled player or their scorer
or their agitator then the enforcers job
is to stand up for them and that is
something that they take great pride in
that the team that brings the team
together that Bond's the team and that
so so a couple of elements in hockey
that are really really remind me of a
well-functioning honor culture there are
all these unwritten rules about what
you're allowed to do and what you're not
allowed to do and there's a kind of
informal enforcement of those rules
through the fights through the brows
through the the kinds of hits that
they'll make on the ice and the
officials have to use a lot of
discretion in terms of how to how to
manage it and whereas in the NBA if you
even step off
to the bench when there's a tussle
you'll get fined and suspended for the
next game in hockey the officials are
are really just trying to figure out
what's the best way for them to resolve
this dispute to handle this dispute in a
way that will that everyone will come
away as satisfied as possible
basketball axe that football probably
lacks that by necessity although you
could definitely make the case that
football is an honor culture as well now
with baseball I mean the biggest way is
the bean balls and and the codes that
underwrite when you can hit a player and
run you can't so you know a lot of times
a player is hit because they show
disrespect to the other team maybe by
jogging too slowly around the bases
after a home run maybe by sliding into
second base the wrong way but then also
there is this kind of retaliation if if
your own player has been hit the pitcher
is expected to go out and hit a batter
that sort of that that person's their
own the the person who has hit on their
own team their level their status now
the pitcher is is supposed to hit the
opposing player and even though that
opposing player didn't do anything wrong
there's this idea of collective
responsibility and collective punishment
so yeah baseball and hockey are the two
examples that I use a lot because of
these elaborate almost Byzantine
unwritten codes and and all built around
the idea of respect and accountability
last thing I want to touch on in the in
the very limited time we have left are
rules that are established through a
sort of honor infrastructure more
difficult to dislodge than non honor
based rules so like as an example if
it's considered dishonorable for women
to work outside the home in a society is
that going to be more difficult to
dislodge based on it being as a sort of
honor rule than other types of rules
hey that's an interesting question I
don't think so because so much of the
way rules or norms in honor cultures
they're often either unwritten or
informal they're constantly evolving and
constantly the subject of debate and
dispute within the community whereas in
a non honor culture there's often legal
bureaucracy to get around to change a
rule even that everybody knows is unjust
I mean think of marijuana laws or
something and how long it's taken to get
and now you know there's a lot of
acceleration but all the legal hurdles
you have to jump through to change a
rule that you know has very little
support within the population you just
don't often have that in honor cultures
because they don't approach legislation
in such a bureaucratic way absolutely
fascinating topic the book is why honor
matters we've been speaking with the
book's author Tabler summers who's a
professor of philosophy at the
University of Houston you can also check
out the podcast at which he co-hosts
very bad Wizards so great to talk to you
about this yeah well thank you for
having me